good evening everybody good evening
members could i please have your
attention
and could i ask you please to find your
seats now
um thank you for being so patient we
it's taken a little bit longer to get
everybody in than
our normal processes would um
allow for so uh but i think we're now
ready to start so i will hand over to
tony
foreign
hmm
please be seated everybody
good evening councillors ladies and
gentlemen and welcome to the annual
meeting of trafford
borough council before we formally start
this meeting
i invite my chaplain father gerald
murphy of saint anthony of padua
stratford
to lead us in prayer
i'm looking for the roving microphone
yes
i begin in the name of the father and
the son and the holy spirit
amen god our father we come to you
with the needs of the whole community of
trafford
we ask your healing and comfort for
those in grief
or those recovering from coronavirus
we ask for hope for those who've lost
their jobs or had their hours cut
and for those businesses trying to
rebuild
we ask for your strength for those most
vulnerable
the elderly those that food shelter or
clothing
and we ask for the gift of wisdom for
our counselors and officers of trafford
make all their decisions be guided by
and rooted in and desire to build up the
community
in which we live and we ask this through
christ our lord amen amen
thank you father jed
and apologies for absence have been
received from councillors chilton and
myers
i've also been advised that due to work
commitments councillor dr barclay may be
delayed by traffic
are there any other apologies
oh council children is actually here
councillor tom very welcome
councillor thomas and
doctor dr barth is here um
somebody mentioned another counselor
earlier counselor whitton
counselor thomas council admires we've
got
anybody else there was a green party
member that might be late
he's here now right thanks you're all
here that's great um
as we are holding our meeting here at
the cricket club we do not have our
normal voting up
facilities so any votes this evening
will be
by a show of hands the next item is the
minutes and a move to the minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of march
2021 be taken as read and signed as a
correct record
is that seconded seconded mr mayor thank
you all in favor
aye thank you item 4
noting the results of the recent
elections may i welcome councillors
jill oxford
just deal with items one and two
okay we'll just have a pause for a
second everybody um
the meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's
committee meetings youtube channel the
whole of the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
and this activity promotes democratic
engagement in accordance with
section 108 of the local government's
act 1972 so just to remind
everybody that this meeting has been
live streamed
um
okay so um i'm actually reading from the
wrong script to everybody
we'll start again item one first item is
a little different this year as you will
be aware
because of the extraordinary
circumstances over the past year the
council modified
the mayoral terms of office to cover the
remainder of the past municipal year and
the new one about to begin
therefore at this annual meeting the
council simply asked
to note that the annual meeting held on
the 25th of november
2020 when i was elected to serve as the
mayor and chair of council
for the remainder of the municipal year
and for the whole of 2021-22
municipal year i hope you all
understood that my wife mrs rachel welch
has been appointed as my marist
on that for that same term can i ask for
this to be noted by the council please
thank you item two similarly the term of
office of the deputy mayor was extended
at the annual meeting held
on the 25th of november 2020 and council
is asked to note that councillor chris
boyes has been elected to continue to
serve
as the deputy mayor and vice chair of
council
for the 2021-22 municipal year
and that he has appointed his wife mrs
pamela boyce
to act as his deputy mayor s please
can this be noted at this annual meeting
hi thank you item three is the minutes
the next item
and i mean that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of march 2021
be taken and read as a correct record is
that seconded
seconded all in favor i
item for election results noting the
results of the recent elections may i
welcome
councillors jill oxford jed carter
daniel chulkin
shona gilbert wazim hassan sarah harhi
sue maitland and mustac merza
to their first council meeting and
welcome back
councillors louise dagnol dolores
o'sullivan and michael wetton
who are rejoining us congratulations to
to all the members who were successfully
re-elected the terms of office for
everyone elected
are set out in the report and he asked
that the council
note this thank you item five
the council is requested to note the
continuation of the leader of the
council's term of office
until the expiry term of office as a
councillor in 2023
i invite the leader of the council
councillor andrew weston to appoint his
deputy
and the members of his executive
councillor weston
thank you mr mayor as per the report my
deputy will be councillor catherine
hines
and my executive appointments are as set
out in the report i so move thank you mr
mayor
thank you very much item six the council
is asked to note the membership of the
shadow executive
can that be noted please i
thank you item seven is the appointment
of council committees and i
invite the leader of the council to move
the recommendations for the proposed
committee structure
and memberships for the 2021 2021-22
municipal year
so move mr mayor thank you
is that seconded it's seconded mr mayor
thank you thank you the motion has been
moved and seconded
is that agreed thank you
item number eight is outside bodies may
i ask the leader to move that the
outside body nominations made by council
be agreed or set out in the report
schedule and for him to appoint those
bodies
which relate to executive functions
that's so moved and as set out in the
report mr mayor thank you thank you
councillor weston can you have a second
to please for council appointments
that's seconded mr mayor thank you thank
you all in favor
aye aye item number nine
um and the council is requested to agree
the calendar of council and committee
meetings for 2021-22
at this point i would like to invite the
corporate director of governance and
community strategy
to advise on the arrangements for
meetings in light of the government's
road map
out of the pandemic
thank you mr mayor it's just simply to
um say that obviously at this point in
time
because there's still some uncertainty
about when restrictions will be fully
lifted um for the time being meetings
will have to take place
outside or away from the town hall
because we're not able to hold most of
our meetings in a socially
distant way in the event that
restrictions are lifted further on june
21st then it is likely that we will be
moving back to town hall
but we will be advising members of the
venue so you
need to obviously keep an eye on
agendas as they're issued for the venue
for meetings but we will try and get
out um timely information for members as
well
in terms of each member each meeting and
where it's likely to occur
thank you with that information please
can i ask the leader of the council to
move this item
that's moved mr mayor thank you is that
seconded
it is a seconded thank you mr mayor
all in favor aye item 10
please can you ask the council to
approve approve the committee
arrangements
for dealing with delegated decisions and
urgent action
assets are set out on the council
summons is that agreed
thank you item 11
council is asked to confirm the
arrangements for the delegation of
council
and executive functions council also
requested to agree
constitutional changes in respect of
employment procedures
first of all please can the leader of
the council move that both executive
and office office scheme of delegation
be reconfirmed without any changes
i'll move that mr mayor thank you thank
you is that seconded
it is seconded thank you mr mayor thank
you the motion has been moved and
seconded
is it agreed thank you
turning to the report on the employment
procedures
can i now invite councillor russ the
executive member for finance and
governance
to move those constitutional amendments
councillor ross
thank you mr mayor um now that i'm up as
well say a couple of words
um the changes are to ensure that the
standing orders within the constitution
reflect the statutory position following
a recent review
um and i'm happy to move the report
thank you
thank you councillor ross is that
seconded seconded mr man
thank you the motion has been moved and
seconded is it agreed
um item 12 the final report this evening
details the executive decisions
which have been taken under the special
urgency provisions
and is for the council to note can i ask
for
therefore that this be noted all right
that then is the end of this meeting but
before you go
can i wish manchester united every
success
in their europa league
can i wish manchester united every
success in their europa league final
this evening
and can i also wish manchester city
every success in their champions league
final on saturday
thank you thank you for your attendance
and i hope you enjoy
the rest of your evening thank you
everybody
can i just ask you all to wait while the
mayor
is escorted out please
we all stand please thank you
all done for another
said about year
you